don't fall for counterfeit software this
Autumn visit software keep software keep
is the digital destination for authentic
software Solutions and amazing deals hey
42 here on the 22nd of December 1938
South African fisherman Hendrick houon
was sorting through his catch when he
came across a fish he'd never seen
before it was about a meter and a half
long and covered in thick armored scales
that shimmed and an iridescent blue as
an experienced Captain Yen rarely saw
fish he didn't recognize so he called
the local Museum to see if anyone knew
what it was they didn't in fact the fish
looked like no species anyone had ever
seen actually that isn't quite true
there was one kind of fish this strange
specimen resembled a species called a
celic camp but there was a slight
problem with that celic camps had been
extinct for more than 60 million years
or had they fast forward more than 80
years years to today and that weird blue
fish is widely considered to have been
one of the greatest Zoological
discoveries in history after all it
isn't every day that a creature known
only from ancient fossils randomly turns
up in a fishing net but the caam story
is about more than its seriously
spectacular return from Extinction this
is a creature unlike anything else on
Earth amongst its many accolades it's
the oldest surviving species of fish on
the planet having first appeared more
than 400 million ion years ago it has
the longest gestation period of any
animal at 5 years and remarkably enough
it is more closely related to you than
it is to any other fish alive today just
in case it wasn't enough for you this
not so humble fish has even found itself
at the center of one of the biggest
debates in human history Evolution
versus Creation With both creationists
and evolutionist believing the ca Camp
proves that they're right about the
origins of life on Earth intrigued you
absolutely should be because this is a
story of the ca Camp the fish that came
back from the
dead software keep is the digital
destination for authentic software
Solutions and amazing deals their aim is
to arm their clients with the digital
tools they need for Success standing as
a beacon of trust offering genuine
software at prices that challenge the
norm as an influencer with a home office
it's essential that I have the latest
software and I know it comes from a
legitimate s and it's nice to know I can
trust software keep as the leaves change
and the season turns software keep
invites everyone to elevate their
digital experience with genuine top tier
software Solutions their awesome sale
offers deals so enticing they perfectly
match to season's charm seiz to season
and snag these awesome deals before they
gone and a quick heads up you can use my
promo code 4020 to get great offers on
software right now whether you're
searching for Microsoft Office 2021 or
Windows 11 software keep has you covered
software keep is a Microsoft gold
certified partner and they have
affordability like no other click my
link in the description box now and use
the promo code 4020 to get great offers
on software right now thanks to software
keep for sponsoring this video Lou aasis
was one of the most important
naturalists of the 19th century a
professor of zoology at Harvard amongst
his many impressive achievements he
founded the scientific discipline of
glaciology and created the
world-renowned Museum of comparative
zoology but probably his most famous
work came in the field of it theology
that's the study of fish for those of
you who don't speak fluent Greek aasis
classified hundreds of fish species
during his long and illustrious career
including everyone's favorite horor from
the deep the Megalodon but in 1839 he
described another new species a slightly
less impressive specimen identified from
an 8 milliony Old fossilized tale he
named it the caamp though nobody at the
time really gave a toss this was the era
when the first dinosaur species were
being discovered and with house-sized
reptiles hoovering up the headlines the
classification of a random prehistoric
fish didn't make much of a splash at
least not to begin with that all changed
20 years later when some English bloke
called Charlie published a book called
On the Origin of
Species Charlie surnamed Darwin had come
up with a fancy new idea he dubbed the
theory of evolution and it sent shock
waves through the scientific world and
Beyond before Darwin Western scientists
have been convinced that this Origin of
Species business could be described in
threee short words God did it after
Darwin well there was one hell of an
argument most great scientific
breakthroughs Force us to rethink the
way the world Works Darwin on the other
hand was asking the human race to
rethink how their religion worked
unsurprisingly plenty of people didn't
really fancy that and some made it their
mission to pick Holes In Darwin's new
fangled ideas one of the biggest
arguments against the theory of
evolution was the lack of so-called
transitional fossils in other words a
species slowly evolves into other
species over time where were the fossils
of the fraking weird hybrid things that
must have existed in between and here's
where the caam fits neatly in in the two
decades since the gases had first
described a species several more
complete cicam fossils had been found
and they exhibited some unusual
characteristics most unusual of all were
its fins which could be found on the end
of sturdy leg-like appendages called
loes these loes contained bones that
correspond to those found in the upper
arms and legs of land vertebrates and
they were connected to distinctly un
fishy shoulder joints similar to those
found in modern reptiles and scientists
didn't know it at the time but cicams
also had a small vestigial look lung
that had no business at all being inside
a water breathing fish in other words
the sea Camp appeared to be a darwinists
Holy Grail a genuine transitional fossil
and this wasn't just any old transition
it was one of the biggest and hardest to
explain in the entire history of life on
Earth the evolution of land vertebrates
from
fish almost overnight the sea Camp
became the poster boy well poster fish
for supporters of Darwin's theory of
evolution who believed it was the fabled
missing link between fish and tetr pods
the first fish to flop out of the ocean
and have a cracket life on land over the
following decades more cicam fossils
were found the most recent were around
66 million years old and the oldest were
a staggering 410 million years old to
put that number into context the sea
Camp evolved before
trees by the early 20th century Darwin's
theory of evolution had had cemented
itself as a foundational pillar of
mainstream science it no longer had much
need for a poster fish and so the sea
Camp once again faded Into Obscurity
only getting referen now and then at the
annual ich theologist pub quiz but all
that changed once again in 1938 when out
of nowhere the ca Camp flopped its way
onto the front page of newspapers all
over the world margorie ctin Latimer was
the curator of a museum in the South
African city of East London yes that is
in South Africa and I too was surprised
by its name anyway part of her remit was
to investigate any unusual Wildlife
found in the local area so when she got
a call from one Captain hendrik yon's
asking her to have a look at the unusual
blue fish he'd caught in his trolling
net she headed out at once by the time
she arrived at the scene the fish was
already dead but as soon as she laid
eyes on it she had a feeling it was
something special using power of
persuasion worthy of a Jedi marjerie
convinced a local cab driver to bun the
man-sized Slime covered fish into the
boot of his car and take it to the East
London Museum the initial reaction from
the staff there was actually a bit of a
disappointment there was General
agreement that the fish looked a bit
dodgy but the Museum's chairman thought
it was probably a common rock cod that
had fallen out of the Ugly Tree Marjorie
wasn't convinced she trolled through the
Museum's fish books and couldn't find a
match with any of the hundreds of
species known to live in the waters off
the coast of South Africa or anywhere
else for that matter she needed a second
opinion preferably an expert one so she
made a rough sketch of the fish and
posted it to an ich theologist friend
called jlb Smith along with a brief
written description of what she'd found
while she waited for a reply Marjorie
had some more pressing concerns to worry
about namely what am I going to do with
this massive fish it was smack
in the middle of the South African
summer and things were starting to get a
little fruity the music Museum didn't
have any preservation facilities so
marjerie tried her look at the local
morg instead perhaps unsurprisingly
considering she'd bought them a 60 kg
fish instead of the more customary dead
human they told her to get stuffed and
that gave her an idea perhaps the local
taxidermist could help it wasn't ideal
Taxidermy is a far cry from scientific
preservation especially since the first
step involves lobbing goly internal
organs right in the bit but with no
other options it was the best she could
do by the time jlb Smith's reply arrived
the unidentified fish was stuffed and
mounted for display and the contents of
Smith's letter were far more positive
than marjerie could have possibly
imagined he was confident the find was
of huge scientific importance because as
far as he could tell Marjorie had buged
herself a sea Camp when people tell this
story they often Overlook just how
insane that call actually was I mean
just think about it for a second based
on a simple description and the crappy
drawing Smith correctly concluded that a
fish he'd never set eyes on was a member
of a species known only from fossils
That was supposed to have gone extinct
more than 60 million years ago seriously
give that man an albatross it will be
more than a month before he eventually
made his out to East London probably
because he went to the wrong one but
once there he confirmed his initial
suspicions he named this previously
known species of SE camp lamaria columna
in honor of margerie and prepared to
take the find public scientists are a
fairly stoic Bunch but when the news of
the caam's discovery or should that be
rediscovery got out ich theologists all
over the world lost their Collective
it was like finding a velociraptor
wandering around the car park at your
local Tesco this was a creature that
should not could not exist and yet the
evidence was irrefutable somehow how
cicams had survived the last 60 million
years and just nobody had noticed
species that are for to have gone
extinct only to suddenly reappear again
are called Lazarus taxa and they are
incredibly rare only about 350 have ever
been identified and the overwhelming
majority of those are species that were
believed to have died out relatively
recently in the last 100 years or so
there were only a handful of examples of
species that were found alive after
first having been identified in the
fossil record that made the newly found
CA Camp a big deal but unfortunately the
only specimen known to man was in pretty
bad shape after having been stuffed like
your Nan's dog having evaded human
attention for hundreds of thousands of
years the caamp suddenly became the most
sought after fish on the planet
scientists wanted more specimens to
study and Aquariums wanted the world's
hottest fish to bring in the punter so a
large reward was offered to anyone who
who could catch one alive thousands of
people tried and for a while there were
fears of overenthusiastic fishermen
putting the species at risk but despite
this mad rush it was 12 long years
before any Celia Camp was captured no
bloody Wonder they've been hiding from
humans and other species for 60 billion
years I would have as well but despite
this mad rush it was 12 long years
before another Celia Camp was captured
this time in the waters of the kamaro
islands the find was of such scientific
importance that the South AF afan
government immediately scrambled a
military aircraft to fetch it and you
can't really blame them this was an
opportunity that was perhaps unique in
all of human history we usually have to
guess what long dead creatures were like
by studying their bones it's a difficult
process and even with a full skeleton
certain attributes are practically
unknowable for example we still aren't
really sure whether dinosaurs were warm
or cold blooded the second cely cam
specimen fresh and unmolested by the
rigers of Taxidermy was a chance to put
flesh on Ancient bones
it was like waving a magic wand and
bringing a 60 milliony old fossil back
to life thanks to that second specimen
and around 100 more Celia cams that have
been caught in the years since we've
learned so much more about these
incredible creatures that we ever could
have inferred from Bones alone for
example we now know that Celia camps
move their leg-like loes in an
alternating pattern a bit like a horse
trotting giving them amazing control in
the water they've even been seen in the
wild swimming on their head and even
upside down they grow slowly reach
sexual maturity later in life and can
live to be over 100 years old they also
have the longest gestation period not
just of any fish but of any animal known
to science with Celia CF embryos
gestating for at least 5 years before
they hatch okay now for the big
questions how is it possible that this
species was unknown for so long and why
did the Celia Camp drop out of the
fossil record for more than 60 million
years let's start with the first one we
didn't know C cams were still alive and
flipping largely because of where and
how they live for starters they're deep
sea fish spending most of their time
around 200 M below the surface that's
obviously true of a lot of other fish
too but Celia camps are also nocturnal
hunting only at night crucially they
spend their days sleeping in deep sea
volcanic caves far Out Of Reach of
fishing nets as for why they dropped out
of the fossil record that bit's actually
surprisingly simple I mentioned earlier
that the most recent celam fossils are
about 66 million years old and that
number may have rung a few Bells because
it was about 66 million years ago that a
big off asteroid smashed into Earth
wiping out all the non-avian dinosaurs
and tens of thousands of other species
besides until we realized that rumors of
their Extinction had been greatly
exaggerated we thought the asteroid had
killed the Celia C too obviously we now
know that wasn't the case but it's
likely the global catastrophe
dramatically reduced Celia Camp numbers
most Celia camps we know from the fossil
record lived in Shallow Waters and some
were even freshwater species that lived
in lakes and rivers those ecosystems all
have something in common unlike the D
potions where Celia hams are found today
they're very conducive to Fossil
formation put those two things together
the dramatic decrease in population size
and the move to a habitat where fossils
rarely form and it isn't hard to see how
the Cel c pulled off its great Vanishing
act it's now more than 80 years since
the Celia C came back from the dead but
it remains an extremely important
species
even today in 2013 its entire genome was
sequenced for the first time and we
discovered that hard as it is to believe
these incredible creatures are more
closely related to us than they are to
Modern fish scientists also discovered
that the Celia Camp isn't quite the
missing link between fish and land
animals that we once thought it was that
honor belongs to an unknown ancestor of
the lung fish the only other surviving
Globe finned Fish whilst that sadly
means you and I don't have Cela great
great great great great great great
grandparents in some ways that makes
this weird fish even stranger an
evolutionary Oddity that almost made it
onto land then disappeared into the
depths of the ocean instead you'll often
hear the Celia C being referred to as a
living fossil because it remained
largely unchanged for 400 million years
for that reason some creationists now
considered the species to be a shining
example of why Evolution doesn't exist
after all if it did How could a species
survive for hundreds of millions of
years without evolving it's an
interesting question but ultimately a
flawed one because it's built on a false
premise like every other animal on the
planet they are evolving their outward
appearance may not have changed that
much but their genome has Celia camps
are a textbook example of what's known a
stabilizing Evolution their natural
habitat deep down in the Indian Ocean
has remained pretty much the same for
millions of years so there's been
relatively little change in the kind of
selection pressure that might stimulate
the spread of new phenotype variations
it's the evolutionary equivalent of if
it ain't broke don't fix it in 1997 a
couple on their honeymoon were wandering
through a quaint Fish Market when they
spotted something interesting a large
fish with distinctive lob shaped limbs
denly Weds happens to be scientist he
was a biologist and she was a naturalist
and they recognized the animal at once
it was a freshly caught Celia camp that
in itself wasn't all that remarkable
this was 60 years since the Celia Camp's
rediscovery after all what was
remarkable however was the location of
the fish market in the city of Mando on
the Indonesian island of salisi that's a
good 6,000 miles away from the only
known Celia cam population after sending
the fish away for DNA testing scientists
discovered that not one but two cam
species had been hiding from us all
along today the West Indian Ocean
variety discovered by marjerie Corton Al
latima in 1938 is considered to be
critically endangered with only about
500 surviving individuals and there
around 10,000 of the more recently
discovered Indian Celia camps it's
thought that human activity May soon
push these ancient species to Extinction
the rediscovery of the Celia Camp may be
the greatest Zoological find in modern
history for us but it may prove to be
the greatest disaster of the last 400
million years for those incredible fish
let's just hope they can pull off just
one more miracle and survive us thanks
for watching just a quick word to say
that I couldn't make these videos
without the support of my patreon
members consider joining the exclusive
42 Discord Community by supporting me on
patreon it's a great place to discuss my
videos with like-minded individuals and
myself the links in the description but
if you don't want to or you can't join
my patreon then please don't worry as
simple like or comment to say thanks
would also put a huge smile on my face
thank you